thank you
hey everybody and welcome to an invasive
wild ride with Stevo I've become quite
good friends with this week's guest
violent Jay of the Insane Clown Posse
and I just somehow felt comfortable
right out of the gate saying let's look
at your celebrity net worth on the
internet and talk about that and man
that's not the only time that I was
invasive I mean sheesh I went ahead and
made this one a very very juicy podcast
which I'll probably catch some backlash
for but I want everybody to know that I
I kept checking in with Jay like hey man
just want to make sure that you're not
bummed that you're not everything's cool
and I'm very confident that everything
is cool with Violent J and I'm also
super confident that this episode is
wildly entertaining so let's get into it
our people no
yeah well I mean I know uh I know that's
true about juggalosis they love you guys
you know what I mean
hey how was how how was uh uh
WrestleMania
it was like I
don't know that I've ever seen
that [__] So Dope right it's like 70
000 people right that's what I'm saying
yeah that's insane crazy I when when I
heard all you guys were there because I
was gonna go oh yeah you guys are big
wrestling [__] yeah we we did wrestling
you beat doink and Dink no well Doink
the Clown yeah no but we never actually
got to got to wrestle him you know what
I mean yeah yeah yeah I was reading
about that yeah you're a [__] huge
fan so we got to wrestling in WWF we got
the wrestling WCW I already know that my
editor is gonna insist on keeping all
this in for sure to get this out of the
way ladies and gentlemen Violent J yeah
yeah In the Flesh that's right up in
this piece yeah you're joining
um an illustrious group of people who
were once on the podcast via zoom and
uh back for a second episode
hey man this is sitting here all
conveniently yeah yeah that's for you I
know I've seen I've seen you guys
drinking this have a sip and look at the
camera
yeah delicious
so a lot happened since I saw you last
um and let me ask you uh out of the gate
what are we promoting uh I'm going on
the second leg of the three-headed
monster tour okay yeah and the
three-headed monster this year icp's
kind of um well we're taking the year
off so to speak okay so that means for
us
we only released eight songs so far this
year and
um we've uh we're only doing uh our
annual events which is the Gathering
Hollow Wicked uh the big baller
Christmas party jugular weekend and
um a couple Festival dates
so for us that's that's ICP taking the
year off you know that's Hiatus yeah
yeah so uh Shaggy's on tour and uh I'm
going I'm going on tour again we both I
think he might be finished with this
towards if it's not finishing this week
but um he's he he's doing the first leg
I already did the first leg with the
three-headed monster which is like my
side project yeah which is me ishan and
Ouija Mac all on tour together as one
group as the three-headed monster okay
all right and now yeah so it's still
it's a different thing for us okay
the uh new development on the Wild Ride
podcast is that not even on camera we've
got Isaac up there pulling up uh stuff
on the internet for us to look at for us
to share with the audience and this is
probably a totally whack move but I'm
very interested in what the internet
thinks your net worth is ooh can we look
that up to have you ever looked at your
own celebrity net worth I have but I
don't remember it oh yeah yeah because
it was yeah I don't remember let me tell
you why I find this particularly
fascinating because the business model
of ICP is like it
it's
it's fat it's
unique your pioneers of your own like
guerrilla marketing you own your own
label right so you own your own
publishing yeah like there's uh this
rabid fan base the way that you sell
merch is like Second To None you've got
the Gathering you just reeled off like
how uh like active and and and
productive okay so that since you've got
13 million now um that that's a good
chunk of change and I'm not asking you
to confirm or deny if you have 13
million but what made me interested in
this is that uh talking to you and
talking to Shaggy like it's been
impossible for me to discern if you guys
are super humble and understating like
how financially successful you are or if
you're genuinely like out of your minds
and don't even know what you're doing so
basically blink twice if you have 13
million
I'm afraid to say nothing
um and by the way apologies if this
is totally disrespectful oh no bro I
wouldn't even I just front if I didn't
want to you know what I'm saying yeah
yeah
you know we've been doing things
ourselves for so long that um pretty
much I mean this has been the way it's
been since we made our first dollar all
the money we make goes back into the
company you know what I mean and um
when we started making more and more
money you know it it pretty much stayed
like that right except for we would take
what we needed you get what I'm saying
like we would at we go to our manager
and be like hey can I get a car you'd be
like well what do you want you know and
like that you know then we're like man
how about a house you know okay but we
didn't get paid like that because we
were so from the Grassroots putting
everything back yeah so we didn't get
paid like that like like you like we
should have we were just kids starting
to ban even into our Platinum success we
were like that still yeah we never had
set up nobody came in our world and was
doing our money and setting up contracts
we just kept doing it like we like we
did it so um when we when our our
manager who we started everything went
finally left after like 15 years
um
our our new manager our childhood friend
Billy came in the guy's with us now you
know and um we finally started actually
making uh like a monthly paycheck you
know what I mean but anyway to tell you
to tell you the deal when I look at that
I think if I'm if I'm worth 13 million
it's when I'm dead you know what I mean
like if I die we might be worth 13
million you know what I'm saying like
like all the merch that might sell or
something like that you know what I'm
saying well that says like I don't have
13 [__] I don't even have a I mean I
of course I have a bank account I don't
have
a million in it [__] no I don't even got
500 000 in it or a hundred thousand I'll
keep it real in my personal account I
don't even have a hundred thousand
because everything is in Psychopathic
yeah still that's both me and Joey's
company and also like like the net worth
is not just the money in the bank
account it's everything that you own
Like Houses cars and it's that's what
I'm saying now right but here's the
thing
it's also absolute [__] like for
sure ever right yeah yeah no [__] no
that's what I'm saying look that just
makes it look like I'm chilling on 13
million like I got that chilling in a
bank or something yeah
first of all we don't we're not me and
Joey ain't that type of guys where we
don't sit and live we don't live in
mansions you know what I mean we live in
I live in houses that my mom cleaned
when I was a kid that type of
neighborhood because to me that's rich
you know what I'm saying yeah right
Shaggy uh created the impression that on
the the Gathering of the Juggalos that
like you know you guys are making it
such a big production that you're
actually not making anything no I had to
get it together my brother just told me
last week because we just had the
Gathering he was like there's five
thousand dollars left really let's look
together and that's what we cleared this
year you know after profit you know I
mean that's our profit do you know he
was heartbroken because he works his ass
off yeah you know what I'm sure I mean
dude like Justin what you spend on Faygo
yeah
yeah like do you know the cost I'm like
when you do the Faygo Armageddon like
how many how much that's worth like the
the amount of bottle that you guys uh
I'm sure Billy could tell you I'm sure
it's at the Gathering it's it's a few
see the bigger the stages Yeah the more
favor you're gonna go through because if
it's a smaller I'm well okay well that
kind of varies that's a double this is
double standard because if if you're in
a bigger stage you're gonna use less
Faygo because
um you have to walk to it so it takes
more time you get what I'm saying
depending where you're at now okay if if
you're on a way bigger stage that's when
you double the number of clowns and you
double the number of Faygo on stage so
then you use way more you get it I did I
I missed the Shaggy two-dope one I was I
was sick or I didn't come on the road he
had covered I had coveted and I'm dying
to ask and I don't know what's the
secret but how do you shoot those
[__] things so far so impressive you
know it's also an impressive blast it's
the blast that goes directly into my
butthole from my hello tushy bidet I'm
telling you this is the future man no
more smearing poop on your butt with dry
toilet paper it makes no sense when you
get done taking a dump you use hello
tushy to blast your butthole totally
clean it's like pressure cleaning your
butthole this precise
blast of water is so refreshing and it
cuts down your use of toilet paper by 80
percent I mean the the bidet pays for
itself in under a year and you walk
around knowing that your butthole is
squeaky clean I'm talking eat off of it
clean people and if you've never used
this product then it's time to get with
it because I'm telling you this is my
favorite sponsor of the Wild Ride
podcast hello tushy I've said that since
I started using it and you can have 10
off your first order if you go to
hellotushy.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo again
it's my favorite product that I've ever
promoted on this podcast and it's time
for you to try it one more time get 10
off your first order if you go to
hellotushy.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo your
butthole is going to thank me now let's
get back to it with one hand you unscrew
the two liter bottle you put your thumb
over the top you shake it and then you
just will you turn it upside down look
if you're in a hot club like what we
normally Play 2 000 Cedars right if
you're in a [__] hot club normally
it's hot as [__] anyway so the bagels
baking all night pretty much right such
expanded grab it right you can feel it
you grab it you can feel it about the
pop
you [__] turn to turn a lid that
[__] thing rockets off you stick your
finger in it you hold it like this with
the other two fingers and you turn it
upside down and you're just you're using
these two fingers these two to [__]
squeeze it shut and you can aim it
anywhere and if you don't shoot it in
like three seconds it's gonna build so
much it's gonna shoot itself anyway you
get what I'm saying but the minute you
let go it's [__] flying I mean it's
going like 75 yards yeah man in the
summertime high ceiling in the venue I
thought like you guys had a Mentos thing
that you're putting in there because I'm
like there's no [__] amazing they're
hot they're going on their own yeah and
the flip side of that if they're cold
that's why we don't tour in the winter
no more we were like the whole reason is
you know we don't want to send them out
in the [__] but it's pretty cool we
just said [__] it we're done touring in
the winter it's just not for us you know
plus the fagos are freezing and we've
been forced to go out there with ice
cold Faygo that's been on the truck all
day riding through the snow yeah you
know what I mean it's supposed to be a
couple days off that [__] is almost
Frozen and then me me and Joey are
pouring it over ourselves you know and
throwing silent ass two leaders in the
crowd that don't even [__] rock it
because they're there's no Fizz yeah
there's no yeah have you guys ever tried
to get a Faygo sponsorship Yeah man so
you go we me and my brother were just
talking about this we're like man maybe
there's new people there now you know
what I mean yeah Faygo ain't [__]
with us man is that crazy yeah that's
wild you're the only reason why they're
still in business
they're like we're a family a family
product you know how they are but um
yeah you know I don't know why they
don't [__] Rock it's not like anybody be
mad that is buying it for family
consumption if there was a [__]
hatchet man on it and me and me and uh
Joey in the corner you know real smart
you know that would [__] Crush
their fans wouldn't be angry I don't
think it's not gonna be like [__] Faygo
you know what I mean right if anything
they would just sell more to Juggalo
collectors right yeah you know so I
don't know why they don't dude I uh I'm
just sitting here and I just wanted to
articulate this that like I I feel like
I owe you an apology for putting you on
the financial blast that I did I'm not a
rich kid though right but I'm I'm beyond
Rich
depending on where I came from yeah man
let me tell you something I rented a
Bentley look at me where are we at we're
in the Hollywood Hills yeah I Airbnb to
my [__] Hollywood Mansion yeah right
a Bentley for me in the [__]
um McLaren for my son Jay-Z oh really
yeah just for this trip to Florida I was
like man let's throw it up big I'm from
[__] food stamps and powdered milk so
I am rich that [__] might say I
make 13 million or I have 13 million and
like I said it might actually be worth
that if we sold all our [__] and
everything and our our uh Masters and
everything yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying so I can't say but our finances
are so tied up in the [__] company
that I know I don't have I don't live
like that my house ain't no million
dollar house you know what I mean well
where I live you know so we pull up
Steve's net worth
I I I think it says I'm worth 2.5 Oh I
thought I saw six at one point oh really
well when were you looking upstairs
they bumped me up to four to four wait a
[__] minutes there's no [__] way I
got more money than you son what are we
talking about here
I got 13 million Stevo got four we got
3x what he has yeah dude that guy I man
that is on crack that is so on crack man
I'm just I'm a chump dude
man yeah there's no way there's no
[__] man we're just outside of
Detroit Dodge Stevo was a household name
dog who's left
he's right now yeah what is that where
do they get that
[Laughter]
yeah the guy's a jackass ranked
I think Zach had like 1.5 on there yeah
really yeah it's it's just not accurate
stuff man but why would they think yeah
that's insane but we're cool right of
course Brothers
yeah I'm not come on I'm the last one
how many millions have
3.5
that's probably accurate he does own a
lot of Real Estate
so let's take it back to the wrestling
because I I was reading about you and
you you have an illustrious wrestling
career is that true [__] yeah not not
like inacculates you know not in like
relationships but you started doing the
backyard wrestling yep Championship well
no no no we started backyard wrestling
then we [__] um started wrestling in
the independent scene in around the
Midwest Joe Shaggy would be my manager
you know what I'm saying and um we I
started I was being a wrestler but
that's what really made me and Zoe see
the inside of wrestling though the
dressing room back then they were all
old [__] uh um they were all
old [__]
um uh being mean to us and being cruel
you know what I'm saying yeah I'm trying
to think you could probably pull up my
first wrestling match on here if you
wanted to see it do you have do you have
a lot of wrestling injuries
um no but but uh Shaggy's banged up
really yeah I I originally I'm talking
about news blue out I think that's from
when I was really really fat though man
just just you know I blew it out but but
um
uh Shaggy's got like neck problems you
know but he was the suicidal one he was
always the greatest wrestler you know
what I'm saying like like when we were
in WCW we were actually wrestling they
had us wrestling you know and Joey was
putting on [__] great matches man
just sweet ass [__] blowing my mind you
know and I used to wrestle Joey first
thing we bought when we had money was a
wrestling ring you know we used to we
used to wrestle each other for an hour
every day at lunch
how much does a wrestling ring cost to
put in your backyard because that David
Arquette has one oh yeah they aren't
that bad they're like they're like 1500
or 2 000. that's what they were back
then you know did that just say that you
guys were called the head bangers yeah
that that group was called the head
bangers and and um
you know what I mean but uh yeah we got
to go to man we left a [__] drink
that's what I'm saying if you believe
okay let me get corny for a minute
because it's the truth I can be if you
believe in the secret you know what the
secret is yeah the laws of attraction
the power's a positive thinking let me
tell you something me and me and Joey
from the time you know I was probably 14
and he was 11. we knew we were going to
be wrestlers I'm saying it wasn't even a
question we were like we're going to be
wrestlers we [__] wouldn't hear
anything else we I used to tell
[__] in school you want My
Autograph now because you're not gonna
be able to get it and you'll be bragging
you went to school with me because I'm
gonna be a wrestler you know and I
mentioned you know what I mean like like
we knew it right
when I when I was 17 he was 15 hip hop
started to overtake that dream yeah so
we fought it for a long time denying it
and then when I was 19 he was 17 that's
when we said [__] it we're doing music
right
when we had our first platinum record
okay in 1997 out of nowhere we get a
call from the WWF or WWE now and they
say um hey man um we want you to make
the ring music for this this team we
have called The Oddities
and we were like yeah I remember them do
you know we wrestled and they were like
what are you talking about and we told
them and they flew us out there and we
wrestled uh um at the uh WWE place you
know we wrestled for Vince [__]
McMahon and he and he wasn't in the room
but they say hey videoed it and we
wrestled for their crew and next thing
you know we debuted at SummerSlam you
know what I mean like like with him you
know ringside and then we started
wrestling with him we had a couple
matches in the WWF but when we went but
when we left WWF we suddenly went to
their competition that time WCW yeah and
we did that and that's where we got our
wrestling on you know really yeah it was
[__] awesome man that's us right
there in the WCW
Joey in there getting his ass kicked
right now you know and that's you on the
rubs yeah yeah dude you're 2000 I was at
the I believe final ever WCW event it
was in Panama City Florida during spring
break and I was down there I like the
jackass was oh you were at the last time
it was 2001 March like spring break and
um like I
I was just newly on TV man it was my
first spring break I was the first time
I was in such a huge crowd and everybody
knew who I was and every like and and I
couldn't handle it man like people were
like oh let me get a photo with the
cardboard cameras and like this and that
and like I was just getting mobbed to a
point that like I I kind of freaked out
a little bit and I and I ended up going
into this uh like VIP section and um and
and I'm sitting at the bar next to this
WCW wrestler named Canyon and I said I
said dude one more photo one more
autograph I'm gonna snap I'm over it ah
and uh this guy Canyon looks at me he
goes it just shakes his head it goes hey
man
stop for a second and think about a day
when nobody wants another photo or an
autograph right Canyon was a wise
[__] man yeah as long as it was
for real he was real cool man really
cool man and I thought about that ooh
and that that that really really uh
expanded my threshold for photos
yeah but I don't need to take it away
from you and oh no you know wrestling
has been a part of us from the beginning
you know it has a lot to do with ICP
probably yeah I was just gonna say it
because in all of that you know what I'm
saying I think it comes from uh
wrestling uh background you know I'm I'm
still doing wrestling I I've been
talking with Billy Corgan somehow wow I
know I was on here playing with him
really I I never would have done it you
know actually it's just crazy you know
and um but it's got NWA that's what I'm
saying and so I'm starting there with
them at the um this place called the
chase in St Louis which is historic for
wrestling
you know for this event called NWA 75
which is the NWA National wrestling
Alliance
um 75th anniversary
oh wow NWA is that old
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah way way old
yeah oh [__] man wnwa used to be I mean
NWA became WCW
ah okay yeah after the rap group kind of
took that over yeah
put it down
but Waterloo Iowa
wow that that's uh that that's Epic Man
um you said uh you know you were fat and
and now you look like you lost a lot of
weight you're in good health like uh I'm
doing real good right now yeah you had
uh like like it was a public like like
known thing yeah the heart failure you
had like a real serious health scare
you gotta keep an eye on your health not
just your physical health but your
Financial Health the health of your
business and right now is the Calm
before the holiday storm so it's time to
get in there with ship station that's
how you sell to your audience online
it's how I sell all of my Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole on Amazon
stevo.com it doesn't matter where you do
business if it's Etsy if it's like uh
eBay I mean come on it it's all
integrated into ship station and it's
also ship station has the best shipping
rates from FedEx United States Postal
Service the UPS all baked into one easy
to use interface so that when you get an
order your label prints out yeah
stick your product in the Box slap on
the label and it goes out the door and
that's what you gotta do this holiday
season plus if you go to
shipstation.com and here's the promo
code Stevo they're going to set you up
with the two-month free trial so that
you can find out for yourself just how
easy and affordable it is so go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo what do you get again 60-day risk
free free trial so that you can try out
this service yourself and get to making
money in time for the holidays people
time to make ship happen so
shipstation.com with the promo code
Stevo now let's get back to it [__] yeah
well you know to hear those words heart
failure is pretty heavy yeah you know
what I'm saying just those words
you want those words put together in any
sentences like what the [__] you know so
it was shocking you know what I mean but
I started to notice that I was like um
uh losing my wind you know what I mean
like you know I'll be doing regular
things that I do but I'll be like winded
you know like twice I'm feeling twice as
winter like what the [__] you know what
I'm saying
so when I started getting worried about
it you know I went to the doctor and and
I think this is right be right at the
beginning of covet you know because I
remember the doctor couldn't come down
or no doctor I went to the hospital with
my brother to get it checked out and no
doctors were available because of covet
you know what I'm saying and it sounds
like you're describing symptoms of cobit
because it's a respiratory thing and he
can't breathe right yeah well I could
breathe like I was living with I was
living with with this you know I mean it
didn't happen like overnight where I'm
like why am I so winded you know what
I'm saying I noticed my wind wind
getting worse and I just assumed it was
um
I don't know what the [__] I hadn't been
on the road or something I don't know
you know what I'm saying but but um like
you're out of shape yeah you know but
then I was like this is something wrong
you know what I mean so yeah I've been
living with it you know so anyway when
anyway they ended up
um admitting me the next day and they
were like yeah you got heart uh
something heart failure congestive heart
failure yeah something like that and I
was like what does that mean they were
like your heart's beating irregularly
you know and they're like we're gonna
try to um uh shock it with the you know
and put it back it'll flip back you know
flip back in so they did that and it it
did they did it twice and then they're
like all right we gotta do this uh
procedure called the fibrillation you
know what I mean and they um
they did that right basically and um
I've been back to where I was before I
had heart failure ever since you know
what I mean and they're like it could
last like that
for who knows but it could stop at any
time you know what I'm saying well you
go back to what it was but I want to say
I want to say because right now I'm
totally where I've ever been before any
of that you know like my I don't have an
irregular heartbeat but that could
change you know what I mean but they did
a procedure that stopped it you know
what I'm saying and um I want to say
that before I had that procedure though
we did two concerts you know what I mean
and and I paced myself you know what I
mean and I did it and they were telling
me you can let you can live with it you
just gotta pace yourself you can't be
out here fighting you know what I'm
saying things like that like they were
like you can live with it you can you
can you know you just can't do like you
used to you'll get to know like when you
start losing your breath your skin be
way quicker than back in the day you
know before you had this did they say
you were you had to rock it like fewer
fago bottles
what was the cause of it did they tell
you what's the cause ah [__] man you
know I had I don't know you know the
touring life huh just like being on tour
your whole life and I don't know I was
Heavy a lot overweight oh my God I was
Heavy bro like 450 pounds you know what
I mean like um did it run in the family
being heavy uh well being heavy or even
heart problems no I don't know my dad
you know what I mean but um not in my
mom my mom my mom's still alive you know
what I mean
so um no I don't know but they were like
you know you can live a life but it's
it's it means you gotta step back and so
we were like why tour like we've always
been you know what I mean like like why
go out and pawn a pavement like we
always been neither one of us like doing
it like that anyway you know what I mean
we you know like we would be totally on
the road constantly playing a lot of the
same venues in it we get except for the
time on stage of course the rest of it
sucked you know so we were like we were
like man we're just through the annual
events and so I announced it and that's
when it went everywhere you know what I
mean how do you guys travel around for
tour buses or planes buses it's unless
we're doing like a one-off we'll fly out
and do it or whatever you know yeah
sometimes sometimes we'll fly out and do
three shows and take a van every every
city and then yeah type of thing you
know what I mean when you got buses do
you have your own bus yeah ATT boy yeah
yeah you got him yeah I just went to the
doctor I used to bring our families out
too you know of course yeah you know
what I mean so yeah yeah I went to the
doctor and um everything was fine except
for they said I had a leaky heart valve
oh yeah and I was like and they're like
oh don't worry like a lot of people have
that it's just something to keep an eye
on you got to get checked every year
are you kidding me for real I swear to
God sounds like a [__] car car
problem and then my brother my
brother-in-law now you're like you got
to come get it checked once a year but
like
yeah leaky heart valve they said it's uh
like a high blood pressure thing and so
I'm trying to get my weight down and eat
healthy and heart shit's scary though no
[__] man come on heart failure I can't
deny it what did they did they shocked
you while you were alive I mean I mean
what you were awake put you out you know
and shock you you know and then they're
like oh it didn't work we're gonna try
to get you know you weren't up to
you know no
um you said that uh that that your
health scare became a public
thing like when you announced you
weren't going on towards it like you
said hey Juggalos I need to tell
everybody I want to announce that
because I got this heart situation I'm
now taking a step back from touring
um yeah
we said we're done touring you know
we're gonna do a farewell tour you know
what I mean
um
but we're just kind of putting it off
a little bit a little bit you know what
I mean but um
yeah we're gonna do a farewell tour you
know and um and go around one last time
and go to Australia and go to Canada and
Europe that's around the world for us we
don't we don't ever go to Japan or
anything you know what I mean right
see that's funny if I remember when we
went it was like shortly after we saw
you at your show and was it Ohio when we
went out there I mean we saw you at your
show you mean when I was uh in the Bible
when when I was allowed to do something
that nobody else is allowed to do nobody
introduces ICP at The Gather it shows
his butthole attention
yeah that was a bigger deal like than
anything because I because I thought
like you know hey man I'm gonna I'm
gonna like uh get on stage like they
want me to introduce each Act that comes
out on the main stage so what I want to
do is like do a cool stunt like the cool
trick like for each uh act and then like
each act as a bigger act than the one
before so each introduction gets a
bigger stunt than the one before and I'm
building my way up and then by the time
ICP comes out I'm gonna be straight on
fire and like I even said I was like oh
yeah guys I I'm gonna keep getting
gnarly and gnarly by the time I get done
I'm gonna be on [__] fire and like
this and that and then I I hear yo dude
you can't introduce ICP nobody
introduces ICP like it's a big thing you
know like they just like it's the thing
you just can't do it and I was like I
was like dudes I told all these people
I'm gonna set myself on fire like I
can't tell them I'm gonna do that and
then not do it and like they're like oh
it just doesn't it just doesn't work
that way so I go to Shaggy in jail no
you don't understand that was Billy and
this is the deal
from the beginning oh [__] sorry from
the beginning every time we have a host
you know we always stop there because
what we would do is cut the lights out
on stage and then we we would just all
sudden you know yeah
no no Billy didn't understand that you
were building up for that and then and
that plus we wanted you to do us it's a
big deal to have you there you know what
I'm saying it's actually it's our fault
because we probably should have told
Billy but I just thought he was assume
what we did like yeah let's let Stevo
that's the coolest thing
you introduce us no nobody communicated
anything and right let alone me
communicate to you guys or like nobody
had communicated anywhere and that
that's a law that's been set in stone
for as long as the Gathering has existed
and like Billy saw your butthole and
he's like
this guys
[__] when I see him the first time he
walks up and I'm going to dad like
what's up brother and he goes like Oh or
something he [__] fried my head on
fire
yeah I remember talking about him you're
like is that safe with all the face
changes
look I I failed this word and [__] a
spelling bee I never thought I'd use it
but until I need to now I was
flabbergasted
what the [__] it was like my entire head
went up in a ball of fire but then I was
like I'm fine yeah it is because like
the when I say I'm lighting myself on
fire I had a can of hairspray and what I
do with the hairspray is I spray it all
over my head and then I lie my head on
fire and then Scott over here like spits
lamp oil off my head the Scott blue aim
bottom bottom massive look at that
fireball that Scott blue like you gotta
get a wider shot of that it was it was
big butts so anyway I had that bottle of
hairspray in my hand and I just went
around clicking a lighter and just
blasting the lighter with the hairspray
and dude like when Shaggy had like a bug
land on his face and I burned it off ice
was there
yeah vanilla
ice has been to like almost every single
Gathering of the jugglers there ever was
yeah DJ Paul DJ
Paul's regular yeah yeah [__] he's got a
hatchimal I think Chris Hanson was there
too
[__] boy
Michigan
like we have lunch and [__] Chris Hanson
that's I was you can't be on anybody's
dick no harder than I have been on Chris
Hanson
I would binge watch that [__] so many
times I would question myself like
am I in love with this man you know what
I mean because
and I used to say I had a lyric in a
song I said Chris Hansen is a drug a
little buddy don't know it and I wrote
that when I didn't even know the
[__] remotely and I ended up
knowing them you guys just have lunch
and when you're in town yeah this is my
boy he comes to my house he did a
[__] thing on my house it's so funny
you gotta see it Chris Hansen he's he's
the [__] he did something for us for our
for our social media he walks through my
house and he's going through my house
and it's funny it's really funny man
Chris Hanson Chris Hansen is a good dude
and he did our uh our talk show in my
living room yeah the collaboration yeah
I I am a fan of Chris Hansen [__] yeah
me too man he's so dope and and
um and he's cool as [__] you know he'll
text me probably once a month and just
be like Chris Hansen here checking in
I'm like no you can just say Chris
what's your relationship with DJ Paul
without question my relationship with DJ
Paula is long and wild unlike my bush
which is very short and well groomed
thanks to manscaped that's because I use
the lawnmower 4.0 it is the greatest
Men's Grooming device in the world and I
stand by that as will you if you go to
manscaped.com and use the promo code
Stevo to enjoy 20 off your order plus
free shipping let's face it folks fall
is here and fresh ball fall it will be
if you go to manscaped.com and get that
lawnmower 4.0 that's right plus with the
nose hair and the ear hair get your weed
whacker 2.02 I mean that's the way the
ladies like it fresh and clean and
that's how you should be so one more
time go to manscape dot com here's the
promo code Stevo for free shipping and
20 off your order
yeah dude let's get back to it
because when we saw another thing he
loved you and I was like how do you know
this guy you're like oh dude we have a
we've filmed with uh the Three Six Mafia
for wild boy oh that was for that in
Tennessee like Memphis Tennessee
uh we did a bit with faint and goats we
did a bit with putting gun powder
between two anvils and like firing an
anvil like 100 feet in the air and it
was like three six mafia they were just
like also number two right so yeah they
were number two as well but um
we filmed with them before they won the
Oscar you know it was like uh it was
just like we were down with them and
then they had like blew up and it was
just like we've been super tight with
them and how did you link up with DJ
Paul how did he become part of it man
we've been done with them you know what
the coolest [__] thing is all right
they they do did exactly what we did you
know come up in their own hood super
strong like they used to sell mad
records just in Memphis that's what
helped them grow from there you know
independently just like because Detroit
you know and they were doing the wicked
[__] which is the kind of music what we
call it the wicked [__] right which is
pretty much Horror in your rap you don't
advertise mines are so dark [__] you
know and um so anyway we never knew him
though all sudden in the only group I've
ever known that was actually Platinum
called us up or gold called us up and
was like we want you guys to do a song
with us our wigs was like
like a [__] 10 of sardines when was
that that was um well just another crazy
click what was it
[__] I don't know like 99 wow 99 I think
yeah but um they sent us a platinum
record and everything when it went
platinum but we we booked them for the
Gathering then way back then and they
just came and marked it was only the
third Gathering so this is the this was
the 23rd
or the 24th I think third anyway so
that's that's uh 20 years I've known
them we must have did [__] Us in
three six I think I think we did three
or four songs together maybe more over
the years so epic man and DJ Paul was
just
hammered I did an album with DJ Paul
yeah that's the thing man yeah I
remember because I made a video I put
the video out on YouTube it since no
longer on YouTube because like it's like
a strike waiting to happen kind of you
know um but uh I I put the video before
I put the video out DJ Paul was so drunk
in this video like I shared it with them
before I made it public I was like hey
Paul like I I'm not comfortable putting
this video out without your blessing I
just need you to look at it like tell me
if it's okay like I totally get it if
you don't want to be he's like yeah
what's wrong with it
yeah like uh it is great man I give him
the award for best dressed man I I
follow his Instagram I just love the way
that [__] dresses man I'm on
this dick too I'm not gonna lie I tell
them all time like like you're you're
like a real friend you know what I mean
like like um you know yeah like industry
friends or whatever you know yeah
pause like a real friend you know what
I'm saying DJ Paul is is like a uh good
dude man yeah then you had kid from kid
and play right yeah he was on there yeah
yeah he didn't play DJ Paul uh told me
at one point that uh he wanted to get
into doing stand-up comedy he was trying
to do it and like did I have any any
advice for him and I was like my advice
is to just do it just start doing it and
if you want to come over to my house and
uh work on material like I'm happy to do
that he came over we worked out like a
bunch of material and I don't know if he
ever didn't have you heard about him
getting on stage no I'm thinking about
it though because I know a lot of
wrestlers are doing that Mick Foley yeah
a lot of times doing stand-ups yeah he's
been doing it forever and he's got the
best reputation on The Comedy Club
Circuit like he he and I were like the
the two people who always like every
single person would take a photo with
him after this yeah that's sick you know
I heard even The Undertakers doing that
really yeah that's what I heard like in
other words um imagine you're in the in
the club right or the bar right because
a lot of these guys are playing bars you
know and you're in this bar or whatever
and uh like a massive bar you know and
Undertaker's there to uh it's not too
comedy really they tell stories yeah but
still like you know think about you're
in the bar and all of a sudden they hit
the Undertaker's Bell and they cut the
lights off everybody's like oh for sure
and then he comes out and cracks a joke
you know what I mean everybody laughs
you know like it would be such a good
time you know something different and I
like that these wrestlers are doing it I
like anyway for wrestlers to get out and
get money of course sure is it like
story time or is there they're actually
like doing jokes no they they well I
mean right here you can tell jokes in
telling any story right right you know
what I mean if you you know if you're
that kind of guy and and I like that
these guys are doing it uh um Ric Flair
has been doing a lot of podcasts telling
a lot of funny stories [__] yeah these
guys can get paid to come in and do that
says that Undertaker's community
stylings are described on his website as
the prop comedy Carrot Top meets the
frenetic zaniness of Dane Cook With The
Sassy dash of Amy Schumer [__] is right
see that what a multi-talented ninja
yeah man
dude I love it
um our buddy Zach ass uh hosted the
stage at this most recent uh yeah that's
right he did he did and so so uh I
reached out to Zach like I wanted
like uh I wanted to know
Zach did show the Juggalos your butthole
you know it because they want to see it
that you get on stage at the at the
Gathering they want to see your butthole
that's
speculation on your part I'll tell you
why that's all in your head you can't
hold on
I'm gonna speak on behalf of this
Juggalo but I think I'm speaking for
many
the chant is dope or yelling it when
people least expect it you know yeah of
course right Heckle style right
but when
actually it happens you know what I mean
I think um it's unexpected you know what
I mean
I don't think they they when they're
yelling it I don't know if they're
actually trying to see it
yeah are you the only person that
actually showed your butthole but when
you steal when you do it in front of a
[__] you know of course you're gonna
do it you know as far as I was concerned
I heard show us your books I came off
stage I said to Shaggy I said man it's
so crazy they're screaming and show us
your butthole and Shaggy said yeah they
want to see it you know like they're not
kidding like ask him ask Shaggy has he
ever shown it no shagging that I tried
to shagging my butt off
no yeah that was like the sun he said he
cannot look at it right yeah
um my butthole became an absolute like
thing the star of the Gunner I mean dude
like uh the brown Starve Together
there's the cavernous like like being
Cave of the Gathering and uh that was
the most
[Music]
yeah like uh there I mean dude the way
the lighting and showed Lux this photo
that shaggy sent me from the crowd
that's what it was what an awful [__]
word Lux says it looks like you could
have fit the entire microphone up your
butt without touching aside how the
[__] ever be used in something
delightful or joyous you know what I'm
saying I I think we might be about to
see that there
the crystal clear digital [__]
perfect shot yeah dude it's like better
than reality
that is a double back with the back
Burger
yeah
you should make that an nft
butthole nft I I asked Zach did he show
the Juggalos his butthole and he says I
butt chugged Faygo really I said Bravo
is that a boy Bravo waiter
way to make it your own yeah you know
wait a way to do it like the way to make
it ICP like themed pertinent yeah like
butt butthole at in play butt chug Faygo
that's great do you have overloads how
crazy is sorry to cut you off no no go
for it Juggalos are craziest [__]
everybody knows that
you guys are crazy as [__] you know what
I mean I think you know just we're me
and Shaggy draw the line is naked
buttholes
yeah and pretty much penises you know
what I'm saying naked like in our visual
right well here's well there's a lot of
people walking around naked when we were
driving around the golf carts speak for
themselves they don't give a [__] what
we're they don't care push out on that
yeah
okay you know you're not my dad
go ahead it was it was Shaggy who sent
me that photo text that photo came from
Shaggy like getting it from somebody and
then he texted it to me and then I put
it all over the internet right way to
get in front of it right right I got in
front of it and uh and then here I am
claiming here I am claiming it we don't
[__]
did you get that shot texted doing by
Shaggy wait I got off stage from showing
the crowd my butthole like Shaggy was
right there and I said Shaggy dude I
just spread my butt cheeks as far apart
as I possibly could until it hurt like
and and uh you know and then then the
next day she texted that photo and he
says you weren't kidding me
Jesus so so the thing was that when uh
when I when I saw Shaggy next in person
Scott wasn't there he had covet it was
just me and the gorgeous Paul brisky and
Shaggy on my tour bus and I said hey
Shaggy I want to clear the air you know
the way that my butthole looked in that
photo like it really was just the
lighting I want you to know that that
there's nothing wrong with my butthole
you know and I got up and I started to
show it to everybody he freaked out he
was like what are you doing
he's texting you the picture of it
tripod on a stand and everything it was
so [__] well taken yeah that was
amazing yeah yeah I mean it was an epic
thing man it was an epic thing maybe I
gotta say too that um like not only do I
do I love you I mean I really mean it I
love you did I love who you are I love
the kind of guy you are and I think that
this episode that we're recording of the
Wild Ride podcast is right up there with
the most entertained this is a Non-Stop
entertainment like it's incredible dude
bro I love you too man you know that
right yeah big time dude I tell them for
real you like like man you just like
everything about you bro I could go on a
whole [__] seminar you know what I'm
saying the way the way
he flipped his life you know it was
almost from like one one
um it was it was from one dream match
what is it called one drastic
to another yeah you're saying one like
one extreme to the other thing is one
extreme to the [__] other you know
what I'm saying like like it couldn't
have been farther in One Direction it's
like a full 180. yeah you know what I'm
saying and then and then when when you
get it right of course it's a [__]
extreme in that direction you know what
I'm saying like the [__] you do the type
of person you are how you can almost who
the [__] can't get along with Stevo on
the planet you know what I'm saying and
and you and I have had from from can't
nobody get along with them you know what
I'm saying women more people can't even
be the type person that a lot of people
get along with he's like somebody
anybody in the planet can get along with
now he's got down the bottom you so easy
you know what I mean but then before you
were the opposite in that direction
nobody almost nobody could get alone
after a while you're just like you know
I I read your book I'm reading it again
ah damn for real in your you're seeing
it yourself in the book you know what I
mean okay I gotta get you my new book I
I got it oh you got the new book yeah
yeah sick dude yeah
um oh you know I write about you in the
book the new book listen I tell that
whole I was just gonna tell you I didn't
finish it you know what I'm saying
because I lost it I'll get you another
one I bought it twice that's what every
time I'm on a flight I grab one you know
what I'm saying yeah I bought that book
twice and lost it twice you know I I got
you dog I got you and uh you and I have
been in touch like on a more like
personal level like checking in on each
other like talking about stuff that like
you don't talk about publicly right like
net worths and stuff
Ah that's so funny dude
to what like you and I have talked about
that that you don't necessarily put out
there but I'm asking you because we
haven't been in contact for a minute
like how are you doing and how is your
health and what's going on with you well
you know man
um
I'm doing good man I've been you know I
went through [__]
really epic [__]
roller coaster no man because it was
just
epic bomb after epic bomb you know what
I mean in my life like like two things
in my life collided like at the same
time you know what I'm saying and it was
just a [__] with the death yeah man
everything like that whole time like the
and and then you know coming out of that
my brother and his girl that he had been
with who was working with us you know
what I mean for years like at like eight
or nine years or something like that
they were together and she was all apart
they split up you know what I'm saying
and she went legitimate crazy the reason
they split up is because I guess you
know allegedly her medications or
whatever she wasn't taking them or
something like that I don't know I can't
speak it's not I don't that's just what
my brother's very elusive but anyway she
went crazy though like allegedly right
but anyway and she went on like the war
pass saying craziness you know it's we
pretty much got over it all though you
get what I'm saying right but all that
[__] happened you know that she that
whole Factor was a small thing after
what I just gone through though you know
what I mean like I went through like
just multiple
um bad things coming you know boom boom
boom and um I know you know I never lost
nobody before you know what I'm saying
right and um
it's just you know there's no shortcut
right you know what I'm saying it's like
there's no trick you know what I'm
saying there's no way to get around it
It's gotta wait it out of time eat it
you just gotta let it roll you over you
know you can [__] run deny
try to run around it
is nothing you know what I'm saying
until you just lay down and let it
[__] steamroll you you know what I'm
saying that's what it is man but but
where you're at now like you're like
yeah man I mean no I'm all good man [__]
you know I went to a Trauma Center you
know what I'm saying it was like a rehab
and a Trauma Center in Florida it was it
was both actually was it like a mental
health sabbatical
no it was like uh
how do I deal with this you know and I'm
on drugs you know what I'm saying it was
it was awful you know what I'm saying it
was just like
too much you know what I'm saying yeah
because then like historically you've
not been like an alcohol and drugs kind
of guy no like that was that like when
that crept up like that wasn't your Mo
oh no for not for my whole life you know
what I mean and then like I mean not I
hadn't had a problem in my whole life
you get what I'm saying right and then
and then like it it kind of because that
wasn't your ammo when that was going on
like it was very like secretive yeah
right and so like that that's why I was
like being so careful to help you know I
want to say if you know like
it became secretive you get what I'm
saying I guess I guess you could say I
guess you could say the problem became
secretive you get what I'm saying right
because you had shame around like your
behavior and you didn't want to tell
anybody and it's kept growing and
growing
yeah like no but you know what I'm
saying it just became
um
a problem yeah you know what I'm saying
uh more you know it's weird because I
never actually felt like that you know
like I I I kind of escaped
feeling like it was I I kind of escaped
ever dealing with my own guilt because I
never actually felt it was a problem you
know and maybe I'm stubborn or stupid
but I'm also when I put my mind to
something I've been successful you know
what I mean so for a long time I told
myself I could do that right you know
what I'm saying it's uh it's like when
an alcoholic
really gets bad that's when they start
sneaking drinks and hiding the fact that
they're drinking if I'm hearing what
you're saying like once it kind of
became a problem like you you had to be
secretive about it
and uh and then what I hear you saying
yeah like the most and dude people with
uh alcoholic addictive Tendencies tend
to be the most driven ambitious like
capable people like people who
absolutely succeeded in everything they
tried to do but that alcoholism and
addiction is where that party stops I
was listening to an Andrew huberman
podcast and he was talking about
childhood trauma is is linked like the
more childhood trauma you have the more
successful a person usually becomes
because it's like they're just so
focused on like pleasing other people or
pleasing their father pleasing their
mother like they have to [__] get
this successful goal to like prove it
that they're and so it's it's linked
with childhood trauma on how successful
people are yeah I'm not trying to get to
get you all on blast on this but uh but
I'm assuming anything you want to talk
about bro honestly I I really don't care
like when I say that I mean of course I
care I I don't I'm not ashamed of
anything in my life and the um I want to
say this there's an art to not giving a
thought okay it can be very very helpful
and when you genuinely don't give a [__]
you know what I'm saying and I think
about my life and my secrets and
everything going on in my life and I
think
if the only thing I don't want nobody
seeing me doing is jacking off well I'm
feeling comfortable with that you know
what I'm saying that's the only thing I
wanna but other than that I really don't
give a [__] if a video came out of me
doing anything because I'm not doing
anything that I feel is hurtful to
anybody yeah or creepy in my opinion
because I'll say anything I do yeah I
don't have any secrets you know what I'm
saying that was like the only one I had
really was drugs you get what I'm saying
for that period of my life and but other
than that there's nothing I'm I'm
regretful or guilty of that I do you
know what I mean that's good man and uh
but like with respect to all that like
uh you got your recovery on track yeah
man 100 bro
right like my brother after all that I
live with my brother you know what I'm
saying
my brother called Dr Drew Dr Drew was
the one that suggested the place I went
to you know what I'm saying the trauma
center and the rehab you know what I
mean so
they they set up a plan or something
because um I do random I piss random for
my brother you know what I mean good and
I said to my brother he's like listen
when we start doing these um tests on
don't give me no [__] no matter what
kind of [__] mood you're in you know
and I remember telling them when I when
I came out in uh
um January 1st I said um
I said there's nothing I want more than
to put 5 000 clean tests between this
time period I just got through in my
life and
gaining your [__] trust you
know what I'm saying sure so bring them
[__] on you know what I'm saying and
that'll be time now like my brother if
he's slipping I'll be like rob you want
me to drop you know what I mean he'd be
like yeah you know what I mean but it's
random you know what I mean he'll also
come up knock on the bedroom door you
know what I mean when I'm not thinking
about it you know what I mean and that's
the [__] yeah you know but I don't I
don't have
um
urges anyway okay that's where I'm
blessed yeah I'm saying because I don't
it's just not something that haunts my
mind you know so I don't really that's
why I don't want to go to meetings and I
don't want to um uh um be you know I I
love the sobriety the community and
everything and it saved my life but the
reason I'm not active in it and I don't
want to go to meetings is I I the type
of person I am it's easy for me not to
remind myself of all that you know
because I don't think about it you get
what I'm saying and I think if I did
that I probably would you get what I
mean because I would start to think
about it more than I do and I don't you
know what I mean if that's working for
you yeah man if that if that's working
for you then that's all that matters oh
[__] yeah and and and if it does if it
stops working and you find yourself
going around the loop then you want to
look at it because
no no yeah if even if I started to feel
that way yeah a lot of people have
reached out
the sober Community is massive it's way
bigger than people [__] think you
know what I'm saying yeah and and you
know like I'm part of that community and
I'm like hitting you up like hey man I
don't know what's going on dude people
genuinely [__] care you know what I'm
saying
um and when I say active is I mean going
to meetings and stuff you know it's
because you know
uh bless the Creator whoever is blessing
me I don't have those kind of urges you
know what I mean I don't I don't live
with that you know what I mean and uh if
I did I would [__] be doing something
about I would be doing something about
it you know what I mean like honestly
man it's just not it's not been an issue
for me and I'm so [__] grateful you
know you'd look great thanks man there
are like you look great you sound great
you
uh lost a lot of weight
yeah I gain some though man
yeah you know what are you doing in La
um promoting you know what I mean
getting ready for this tour you know I
want to [__] um
come out and uh bring my girlfriend out
here she never been to L.A three-headed
monster tour that we're promoting yeah
man and Africa bring up that tour
schedule again Isaac where when does
that kick off your girls uh promoting
stuff too
um yeah she's hell yeah how you know
like I got a newsletter from uh uh I
think she's a part of the same like
publicist and I got it last night in the
mail coincidentally
uh girl when I went through everything
you know what I mean
um I just was um
you know you go dark for a long time you
know what I'm saying but it re-emerging
to the world I start going through
Instagram you know what I mean and I
like Instagram by the way you know what
I'm saying I like Instagram because it's
uh quick information and it's everything
everything in the world is on there yeah
you know what I'm saying and um but um
we like Instagram because it's
completely addictive by design it is I
know but I started looking at all the
hotties on there you know what I'm
saying yeah
and um I'd see one model who's got like
millions millions of followers or
something right and I would just look at
who she's following it would be mad
other how do you know what I mean so I
just be hitting all these hotties you
know and literally months and months are
going by you know what I mean and um I
developed my favorites out of two people
and this girl was one of them huh right
her name was Sarah russey
that's
r-u-s-s-i right and um she was like just
queen honey right anyway I never thought
in my wildest dream I could [__]
holler you know what I'm saying so I
sent a [__] um
I just was like um damn like the way you
doing that thing or something like that
you know what I mean and um and and she
was just like how you know or whatever
and and uh I just started hollering you
know what I mean anyway it was just cool
though man and she's dipping to anybody
you know she she wasn't a jogger lad or
a juggalo she just is you know
live in this different life you know
there's only fans she's living out in
Miami you know what I'm saying by
herself she ain't really got a big
network of people out there you know
what I mean it's just her and a friend
or two she hangs with you know and um
it's all about business and the way she
does her thing I I dig the way some of
these only fans do do it you know what I
mean not only fans um Instagram models
yeah because they catch your eye because
they're creative it's like no no for
real you can be in my time you can only
be music you could be sports or you
could be [__] acting you know what
I'm saying but now you can be famous uh
or or a politician or something like
that now you can be famous on these
other [__] platforms because people
are good at that [__] you know like some
of these chicks they work hard like
every day they have a different outfit a
different location like that shit's a
full-time job yeah different [__] you
know hair and everything and you start
to appreciate what they put into their
hustle you know saying and so um anyway
that just made me think different kind
of stepping out of my normal world and
meeting her you know what I mean it's
good yeah
you're happy yeah well I'm I'm I'm you
know depression is a [__] yeah
yeah we're in Ohio at the same time bro
I'm looking at our tour dates you got
Cleveland Ohio on September 8th I'm in
Akron Ohio on September 8th so we're
both on stage at the same time but
September 9th you have no show and I'm
in Toledo Ohio bro get out of here man
because Toledo is right between I mean I
I go home after Cleveland I was gonna
sleep that night after your show now and
head to Boston all right dude let's uh
let's hang out in Toledo Ohio
45 minutes from my house it's sick you
know what I don't I don't promote my
tour enough on the podcast
a lot of people know I'm gonna be on
tour the final shows The Bucket List
tour September 1st in Connecticut
September 2nd Atlantic City New Jersey
September 3rd in Boston
um I got New York Pennsylvania Ohio West
Virginia second show added North
Carolina and Florida
get your tickets dog get your tickets to
the three-headed monster tour start
September 7th in Lansing Michigan then
September 8th Cleveland Ohio September
11th Boston September 12th New York oh
up to Canada we got Quebec Ontario back
down to the States Milwaukee Wisconsin
North Dakota uh a back up to Canada
again if you guys are hitting it hard
Manitoba Saskatoon
Alberta British Columbia back to the
States Washington Oregon California
Los Angeles there you go dude Arizona
ending in San Diego
that's uh that's a [__] heavy run Doc
yes well it's like a month you know yeah
but um yeah man it's fun because um it's
something different you know getting up
there with those guys the routing makes
sense I can see where uh where you're
Crossing up into Canada where you're
Crossing back working your way west
amen
all right where can they get tickets
uh
psychopathicrecords.com pal that's right
uh psychopathicrecords.com acid rap.com
chapter17.com that's Ouija all right
Darren I mean I think this has been the
most explosively entertaining podcast
we've done in quite some time I dare say
getting pretty good at it [__] yeah man
thank you brother thank you I've been uh
getting better at not interrupting
people I only did it like two or three
times
I want to like tell you again if I like
I just went ahead and put you on blast
in in multiple ways dude I hope like
like that no disrespect funny really
because it's an unna you know I tell
people my mom does it my girlfriend does
it it's an unnecessary worry it's like I
wish verbally I could relieve you of
that weariness okay good because but
there's just no way I can do it you know
but it's true it just just not there you
know I I would rather be concerned about
having offended somebody and not then
offend somebody and not be concerned
the first time we met the first time we
met I offended you and I was not
concerned
nowadays I don't offend you and I'm
concerned I'd rather be I'd rather be me
now than I was back then Mom Dad I love
you dude listen one more thing before we
go that rap you did
we're trapped poke the puss or the one
five days a month
ah listen you can rap better than that
no you can I I know I was trying to be
bad yeah I was gonna say quit fronting
yeah I was trying to be bad like uh
recently when I was right maybe maybe
you gotta get me in the studio dude I'm
working on a rap Redemption do a verse
for me on my record I can't do it I love
it really dude like Scotsman been up my
ass [__] when are we gonna rap when
are you gonna rap like let's like just
give me an album cracking dude what was
the Dude where's the nearest Studio
Psychopathic Records dude I'll I'll
bring them all [__] recording machine
to Toledo and be like right
what's this place we came to meet you
this is a house this is a Airbnb or
Airbnb okay so there's no studio in
there no we're doing in Toledo yeah man
if I'm writing like uh like like what
you got to hear the beat first yeah I
can give you the song in advance and
everything okay what do you know what
the song's about yeah listen the wheel
ain't gonna do it together it's about
net worth I'll I'll send you
let me put it together I'll put together
the song
I'll send it to you when you can you can
lay the vocals like anywhere you know
you could probably you don't need a
studio studios are obsolete now anyway
you can do everything in a bedroom it
just is induces good quality sounding as
a studio right you know people just
front and they're old school people like
me I still like to record in the studio
because it's comfortable yeah I'll do it
right here in this van this van that's
what I'm saying I'll send you this I'll
send you the song Lace it up every any
way you want and send that bad boy back
then then maybe let's not even wait
until Toledo like uh I I I've got the
motivation the burden the hand man bird
in the hand let's [__] dive on this
let's make it happen dude all right
cause they always show people how you
can really rap all right dude I'm I'm
down yes
by the way freestyling is hella fine
impressive
but at the end of the day
you know it'll last forever on a song
you know what I mean right right take
your time and really put your your
effort and laces and make it your art
anything you want I'm not knocking
freestyle I'm freestyling is an art and
everything Harry Mack dude will freaky
right right and and I'll have you know
I've got a list I got a white board in
my in my studio at home and it's got all
my all my ideas for for videos and on
that list for the longest time even at
the top of the list it says rap
Redemption I gotta get it back I gotta
make like a track are you serious or an
album I got to make some music that I'm
not embarrassed yes it might happen in
my bedroom my house okay we'll text you
when you get home tonight
um
where it says Redemption
board if I see that on your list for
real it is
I will [__] gladly assist I got a
thing about rigorous honesty Jay like uh
I I I care very much about uh my
Integrity about my word me too and uh we
[__] too yeah man me too yeah look
he's gonna show you [__] that like what
I have there is oh
for sure
I got an old version that that I [__]
oh you don't I think a big shot takes
you when I get home it's sitting right
there I can't even call my lady and have
her take a picture but whatever this has
been epic dude I love you super epic
yeah thank you I love you guys
yeah dude thank you I'm out of here all
right I'm gonna David Copperfield just
yeah watch your head on the way out
absolutely
now right after we stopped recording I
found that image of rap Redemption on my
whiteboard I went running out of the van
chased down Violent J and showed him and
we've already begun the process of
recording our new track
it's gonna be amazing horror rap is what
it is okay and I want you guys to go
catch Violent J on his tour it starts
September 7th catch me on my tour starts
September 1st yeah and
Toledo the 9th of September that's when
we're going to record our music video so
that's a show that you want to be at
um what else can I say man I uh I really
really did check in on Jay multiple
times to make sure that that we were
cool and we are cool so uh
don't be mad at me Juggalos it's all
good and I love all of you guys for
sticking around to the end of the
podcast thank you much and we'll see you
on the road yeah